so uh before we get on with this meeting
of the 11th of november just
a point i'd like to make i think it is
my duty to
i'm not asking to stand up sit down
um some of you may recall um
councillor jack cohen who
was on the council for quite a number of
years he chaired this com
committee for a while and he passed away
i believe it was yesterday um
i thanked linda for letting me know yeah
sorry it was sorry
yeah sunday chair okay thank you david
but
it's my name right for those who know
him um
quite hard to work with but um again
very sad but i'm not going to ask
anybody you know for a minute silence um
okay um so again good evening to you and
welcome to this
planning meeting say 11th of november
i'm going to run through as always
the names of the planning committee i am
aware that there's a couple of um
apologies but if i call their name out
i'm aware that they might not be here so
counselor organ here jeff
councillor bay foot here chair
councillor coleman cook here chair
councillor curry here chair
councillor dennis councillor duckworth
council of ghana i'm here chair
councillor heart
council lakeen yeah chair
uh councillor zesky has stepped in
sometimes but i can't see him there
today
uh councillor scott
councillor taylor
thank you gary councillor right here
and obviously i'm here uh welcome to the
offices as well um so
moving on if you have any technical
difficulties during this
meeting and please contact democratic
services
one call who will attempt to assist you
uh today's officer on call is katie her
number is 57046
her number will be included at the top
of the chat screen
uh for you pure convenience
i would ask all participants to mute
their microphones when you are not
speaking
uh this memorizes background noise and
will help
everyone in this into the proceedings
microphones must only be turned on and
the participant
has been granted permission to speak to
gain
my permission to speak please put your
name
in the chat box and as i said before
members i i do write them down so if i
don't acknowledge you
it's not that i haven't seen them
with everybody present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent
and they're not used to make or receive
phone calls while the meeting is in
progress
also please refrain from checking any
emails or conducting another business
ensure that you are in a quiet room free
from distractions
for the duration of this meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed
for members and the public and following
the meeting
the recording will be available on the
council's youtube
channel members
requesting to speak under 20.1
i have councillor dexter on
item 4b are there any other members
not on the committee who are online who
wish to speak
on any of the agenda items please
no okay
i'm gonna write them down the public
speaking the following applications have
been reserved for public speaking
agenda item for a
gender item for b agenda item
4 d i have received apologies from
councillors duckworth and dennis are
there any other apologies please
now i can see helen there um are you
sitting in helen fur
uh yes shooting for councillor duckworth
right thank you very much agenda item
two are there any other declarations of
interest
no agenda item three minutes to the
planning committee
heard on the 21st of october 2020
do members agree that the minutes of the
planning committee
held on 21st of october be approved and
signed by myself could i have a proposal
please
yeah councillor alvin castle oven thank
you
a seconder oh second that chair
councillor coleman cook
thank you uh do you all agree
great a great chair thank you thank you
thank you uh a gender item for
a schedule of planning and applications
and public speaking
uh once again members um site visits
if there's any decided for site visit we
can't do those at the moment i know i
have mentioned that
things are being looked into um the way
we are with lockdown and so forth once
again
i think you appreciate um we can't can't
do it
uh gender item 4a um planning
application for approval
100 to 114 harbor parade ramsgate
i've asked suki now please to read
the public statement against this
application
thank you claire this is a statement by
mr
ratner singham dear councillors
i write with respect to the application
which is listed for your determination
at the planning committee
hereafter the committee meeting today in
the first
instance i submit that the application
should be dismissed
as the applicant has failed to provide
any evidence that they have
served the proprietor of the garden with
notice of their application
pursuant to section 13 of the town and
country planning
development management procedure england
order 2015.
alternatively and with respect to the
planning officer annabelle heming
she has made a recommendation to the
committee to support the application
which is based on incorrect information
annabelle's recommendation relies upon
the applicant's diagram
which wrongly depicts that the area to
be enclosed as
the roofs of 100 to 114 harbour parade
the applicants diagram is clearly at
odds with hm
land registry's title plan for kent
terrace
the title plan must take precedence over
the applicant's
diagram on the basis of the title plan
part of the area that the applicant
proposes to enclose
with their fence forms the communal
garden of kent terrace
kent terrace is located within the
conservation area
eleven of the houses in kent terrace are
grade two listed properties
on the basis that the area to be
enclosed is not just the roofs of 100 to
114 harbour parade
and is also the communal garden of kent
terrace
the council has a duty in law to
preserve or enhance the special
character of the conservation area
because of the hours are of because the
houses are of historic interest
josie sindon the council's senior
conservation officer
opposed the application on 7th may 2020
in particular she quoted the national
planning policy framework and said
when considering whether to grant
planning permission which affects a
listed building
or its setting the local authority shall
have special regard to the desirability
of preserving the building
or its setting or any features of
special architectural
or historic interest which it possesses
she also said in particular section 16
of the national planning policy
framework states
in determining applications local
planning authorities should take account
of
paragraph a the desirability of
sustaining and enhancing the
significance of heritage assets and
putting them to viable uses
consistent with their conservation the
grant of planning permission would
prevent members of the public from
continuing
to access and use the garden as part of
the area to be enclosed is the historic
communal garden of kent terrace
in light of jose's comments which are
based on statute
and in light of the council's duty of
care in law
to preserve or enhance the special
character of the conservation area
i respectfully request that the
committee does not grant planning
permission for the fence
thank you for taking the time to listen
to my submission
uh thank you i'll now ask the planning
officer to
outline the report uh i believe anna
well
am i correct yes chair i'll just
thank annabelle my screen
um hopefully members can see my screen
thank you i have a further comment just
before i do the presentation that's come
in from the ramsgate heritage and design
forum um subsequent to the agenda being
published
summarize it they say the applicant has
addressed their concerns and lowered the
height of the proposed railings
they consider the details are required
of how the ratings would be fixed
and stabilized and they also
comment that they are aware of a dispute
over the rights to the site
which may be which may merit a
postponement
determination of the application until
this is resolved
i'll now go on with the presentation
thank you
this is the application site outlined in
red
it does include the rooves of 100 to 114
um harbour parade but it does include
a wider area which is also as we'll see
from photographs
flat and hard surfaced so we have
heartbreak down here
we have kent place running off to the
left of the site
and kent paris wrapping around the
application site
and some aerial photographs of the site
so to get your bearings we have the
harbour off
to the left here the weather spoons
royal pavilion
we're victoria pavilion here these are
the
prophecies in harvard parade 100 to 114
and kent terrace wrapping around
looking at it again with the 3d version
you can see harper parade here and it
gives some indications of the changes in
level which exists in this
area with harbour parade
and the properties along it being at a
lower level to
kent terrace and other properties as you
move away from the seafront
and again this is the application site
here kent terrace wrapping round
and the units and harbour parade down
here
so just looking at some photographs of
the site so this is taken from harbour
parade
this is the first part well most of the
teres of units 100 to 114
and around it behind you can see
some of the properties in kent terrace
so you can see the change in levels
between them this is the other
end of the terrace and again you can see
it is a lower level
and kent terrace is wrapping around
behind it
um this is the end of the alaterk um
just scene and as you can see that you
can see the
um entrance to kent terrace and it rises
up behind those properties
and this is turning the corner of the
road we've just seen
you can see the royal pavilion uh weber
springs pub at the rear there
and this is the area that would start to
be enclosed by the proposed railings
this is looking at now in kent terrace
again looking at the area that would be
enclosed so this is the area
that's surrounded by the wall and you
can see the properties in kent terrace
and an area that's being used for
parking and obviously a
a roadway there again looking back the
other way
this is it where the entrance kent
terrace would be the other side of the
properties that form sort of the l-shape
there
this actually gives a good view of the
area to be enclosed
and also the contrast between
uh it shows clearly the railings that
are already in kent terrace set in low
er draw walls along the frontage of some
of the existing
or mostly existing properties here and
this is a closer view of the railings
and you can see them
quite similar along the terrace albeit
there are
a variety of some colors and changes but
they do tend to have the
sort of ferdinance um capping to them
a couple of points have been raised in
the discussion and
throughout the determination of the
application firstly
one is the ownership of the site and
also
um whether the actual site itself the
application site is within the cartilage
of the listed buildings in kent terrace
i'll take each one in turn so firstly um
concerns about the ownership of the site
have been raised the applicant in um
submitting the application um
served notice on one property
and as we've heard this has been
challenged by
some of the local residents saying there
are other
interested part of parties that have
interests and ownership of the site
the in offices have undertaken
land registry search in the last few
days and it has come up with the
conclusion that the applicant does
indeed own
the majority of the site apart from a
small area
at the end here but they have served
notice
as required on the owner of that piece
of land so we are satisfied
that they the applicant is the owner or
has carried
out the required um notification so
we're satisfied on that regard
in terms of whether the application is
within the courtesy of a listed building
the majority as has been mentioned the
majority of properties in kent terrace
are listed and it does appear at some
time historically there was a functional
um potential functional relationship
between the properties in kent terrace
and part of this site um
but it is clear from looking at the site
that this
relationship is no longer there and the
application site is no longer considered
to be
within the courtyard development site um
given things like the change in
ownership um
and the use that's now being undertaken
on the site
so that we do not consider there to be
um
the site to be within the courtroom of
the listed building
and neither does our conservation
officer
so this is the actual block plan of the
site so these
this is the area that would be enclosed
by the proposed railings
it's rather disappointing that the
drawing makes reference to fencing
because it
is actual railings as we'll see as we
move on
but it is essentially you have this this
is the harbour parade here so you have
the walls
and the piece of wall that we saw and as
you entered kent terrace
and then the railings would be proposed
along these
areas here so this is the existing
roof layout
and this is a propose so again the
writings will be located
around here and
it is proposed to be that the ratings
would be wart iron
and would have take inspiration from the
existing railings in kenteris and have
a fleur-de-lis um capped to them
so and this is actually this looking at
the existing
southwest elevations that's the end of
ala turk restaurant
and you can see the wall that climbs up
towards the properties in kent terrace
and this is the proposed um
side elevation so the ratings would be
set into the wall
and there would now be no more than a a
total of 1.2 meters in height
initially they when originally proposed
it would be
they would propose a total of 1.8 meters
in height
which the officers found to be would be
dominating and visually unattractive
so we have negotiated a significant
reduction in the height and the fact
that there would be set within a
a draw wall and again we have
um the north west elevation which is
runs the sort of
longer part of the l shape of kent
terrace so this is the top was the
existing
um relationship where there are a little
bit of raining still in
um place but the war there and this
would be
essentially a drawful majority of this
with the railing set above it
and up to a height of 1.2 meters
so essentially we have considered
albeit that we have a established that
we do not consider that the
um site is within the courtesy of the
listed building
we are aware of the test um
on the impact of the setting of the list
of buildings as well as the
character and appearance of the
conservation area
it is considered that there would be
limited visibility of the railings from
harper parade itself and
and they would be pretty much shielded
by the facade
front facade of the terrace itself to
114
harbour parade so it's not considered
generally there would be
um any real impact from the proposal and
it would
it would seem to preserve the character
and appearance of the conservation area
in terms of the impact on the adjoining
list of buildings
as has already been mentioned the
proposed railings have been reduced
in height and now they are now of a
similar height and design
and materials wart iron to those in
front of the dwellings
and it is considered they'd be seen as
an entity
um within an entity against those
existing railings and would not be a
visually dominant or harmful
feature or in the setting of the listed
buildings
or indeed of the conservation area from
the kent terrace
view so the officer recommendation is
for approval
thank you uh thank you annabelle
um i move that the officer's
recommendation
is for approval could a vice chair
please second
or second nature i think accounts to
coleman cook
um right it's over to yourselves um
i do have uh counselor
heart to start with please counselor
heart
rate chair um overall i don't have an
objection to this
the only caveat i have maybe is that are
they trying to keep people out
or trying to keep people in so um
for an aesthetic point of view i don't
have an objection to it but are they
looking to do this so that they can then
utilize the roof space
as uh an entertaining area
uh and so therefore want to make sure
that people are kept into it and secure
in an area so they can't fall off the
roof
or is this just done literally to stop
people getting onto the roof and causing
damage
and hurt themselves thank you
thank you councillor hart um annabelle
would you like to come back on that
something i thought i must admit yes
chair
um the applicants have advised that
they've had trouble in the past with fly
tipping and people walking across the
roof
um and in some areas the roof is quite
fragile and
obviously not um expecting
um to be warped over on a common basis
and people apparently uses
shortcuts so they are intending to
essentially keep people
out um so it's more to provide that
visual
deterrent to keep people out
rather than yes as you say to um make
use of it and that
if it was to be made use of as a say a
roof terrace with tables and chairs etc
that would require
a grant of planning consent which is not
before us
uh yes thank you for that so council
robin
yeah thank you chair uh firstly yeah i
say i i
i called this in chair because of the
previous application
and representation from the residents of
kent terrace and as for i just got a
reply to annabelle there as for in
relation to what the owners have said
about a shortcut a shortcut to wear
it doesn't actually go anywhere yeah the
roof area
there before the wall was um
constructed i must say the wall in
itself is
a disgraceful bit of construction
and how it was ever approved there uh
for
being adjacent to the listed buildings
and within the conservation area
uh is beyond me however
uh before the war was erected and um
the land that roof was used by the
residents
of kent terrace because they parked
their cars there and as for the roof not
being supportive
the cars were parked on it so i can't
see it not ever being supportive
so um i i dispel all of those chairmen
um i i have to say i i think
uh even if we accept
that the ownership is within or part of
it and the major part of it is with the
ownership of the applicant
they will still be building on an area
of land which which isn't within their
ownership
and i don't i don't accept except that
although that in itself
uh doesn't stop them from applying for
an application that'll be a fight
between the owner of that land and then
however uh the situation of the railings
upon this disgusting wall
um will actually make it very very
enclosed
i went up there this morning to actually
have a look
and for those members who've never been
there i've never been up there
it's a very very tight up there the area
of the you can't turn a car around
when you it when you drive up in to
there you have to back in or back up
um certainly as far as the area
between the railings of the houses and
the wall and the railings that
that that this uh the restaurant wants
to put out
it's very small so therefore in my
opinion share the um
it will have a very enclosed feeling for
the residents
um in fact it'll probably look like a
prison to the red to
the residents and on on that basis
chairman i could not possibly support
this application
and fully support the residents in their
uh in their
um attempt to get to get this stopped
thank you very much chairman
now thank you councillor orban um yes i
recall cars
on the top there a number of years ago
uh council keem
thank you chair um yeah i just wanted
some clarity
you know for the bit that's not owned by
the applicant
i know you said that it's had notice
served on on it
um but has there been any response from
the owner of that part is he supportive
of the plan do we know
i'm not aware there's been a response or
representation from that particular
um owner to us on the application
so i don't know yet whether they've
commented my written through the
applicant
their support or otherwise but yes as
has been mentioned a grant of planning
permission doesn't override any of her
ownership issues so there could still be
third party civil matters that have to
be dealt with in terms of
other owners nice okay thank you
thank you councillor right mr chairman
thank you
um if if we were of the minds who
approved this
application could we put a condition on
it that it could not be used for
any the use of any kind any form of
entertainment i.e
roof terrace garden or
kind of like activity
i'm sure we can um i'll come back to
annabelle on that one can you answer
that at all annabelle
yes that would in need to use it for
those sorts of uses it would need
planning permission
but i'm sure we could put an informative
or something to that effect
onto this consent if members were minded
to go that way thank you uh
i have a question if i may and i think
if it's fair to go to ian
um with um the subject of
um legal proceedings
taking place or maybe taking place on
this
um how do we stand
if approved um
through the committee um
thank you chair um in terms of um in
terms of any proceedings to do with
uh civil matters um and sort of disputes
over ownership
then as annabelle's already mentioned
theoretically consent could be granted
um but obviously it
never means that anyone can
automatically implement those consents
and actually put the
put the railings up i think just to come
back on the point regards to the
the the serving of notice it's as i
understand it from looking at the
application form and then looking at the
land registry documents it's the
it's the tenant of the of the union i
think it's ala turk that's below that's
been served notice on and the
other other person that owns part of the
application site is the applicant
so it's it is pretty sort of
straightforward in terms of
who is down on land registry documents
as to owning
or has an interest in in the site um
as for any separate um you know disputes
between
you know residents of kent terrace with
regards to the site that is
entirely separate and would not be
prejudiced by virtue of
of the committee granting permission in
this instance thank you for that ian
that's just something that came through
my mind uh uh councillor when you wish
to come back
yes please chair just just one one point
chair down to labor
labor the matter um but uh
the roof area to get on the roof you
can't you can't
get from the restaurant to the roof
without coming up the side of kent
terrace and walking all the way around
and plus they would have to put
therefore have to put a gate in and
remove
part part of the wall for them to
actually get in so i doubt very much if
it is for that use but again as
annabelle has said that they will need a
separate application for that
however i would like to say that uh
the wall and a 1.2 meter higher uh
railings will not stop anybody getting
on the roof and
uh the um
the applicant's view of that i don't
really know what is
what this is for whether it's just a
demark
a demarcation part i guess for their
point of
point of view but um i think on the
visual side of it all
um i still can't support this thank you
chair
uh thank you counselor organ um i don't
see
any other speakers so i'm going to put
this to you members
um as usual it is um
down for approval uh could you when i
call your name out please
against um
before against and or abstain
uh council common cook
for council robin against
councillor bayford for councillor curry
against councillor ghana
against council of hearts
for councillor keane
against councillor rashford
again councillor scott
i'll have to stay in on this one chair
thank you uh councillor taylor
can you hear us gary
councillor taylor against
gary uh councillor whitehead
against council right
for and myself i'm against
i think that is uh
that has been refused
so chair the so the motion of the motion
has fallen i wonder if i could
advise the committee at this point
please yes please and thank you
uh thank you so um councillor auburn
sort of
outlined um a few of the particular
concerns with regards to
uh this application um i wonder whether
or not it's worth
just a short discussion on this um
in terms of the previous application
that was refused by the council uh that
was refused
um due to the particularly with regards
to the
the sort of presence of the railings the
height of the railings
in in um kent well sorry adjacent to
kent terrace and it was considered the
that they would appear in congress and
overly cluttered
and failed to preserve the conservation
area and had a detrimental impact on
the setting of of the buildings in kent
terrace um
um in this instance obviously the the
railing height has reduced
um and um but from from cancer auburn
and i might just ask to come back to you
if that's all right
if that's the right chair it's more the
concern and probably
and whether or not this reflects the
concerns of members is
about um the presence of a higher
boundary treatment that encloses that
area
and the impact that has on the
conservation area and the relationship
with ken terrace um is that is that an
appropriate
sort of summation of the particular
concerns
absolutely absolutely and thank you so
on that basis um
i'm i'm gonna um i think it's
um i'm just so i'm just tweaking
something that i'm just
writing so it might be might be worth
just summarizing them and going
through so if i may sort of put
this motion forward and obviously it
would need a proposal and then a second
uh the application that the application
would
would then be would be refused on
uh by virtue of the
the the design and
um and height of the railings
and design there is covering its its
presence so design and height the
railings proposed
would appear in congress and overly
cluttered failing to preserve or enhance
the special character and appearance of
the ramsgate conservation area
resulting in a detrimental impact on the
significance of both the
conservation area and competing with the
list of buildings and structures in kent
terrace
not outweighed by any public benefit
and as a result the development would be
contrary to the aims
of the particular policies and these
particular policies would relate to
design conservation enlisted buildings
so these are qdo2
hg02 heo3 of the local plan
and the particular paragraphs of the
mppf
uh which are relevant in this instance
which is 127 130 196 197
and 200 of of the mppf
um so chair if with your permission if
we could get a proposal
and potentially a second and then and
then a vote on that if
if thank you and thank you for coming
through to that so
um you've heard mr livingston's um uh
thoughts there i'd like a proposal for
i'll propose that chair you know open um
the secondary
i'll second that chair thank you let's
count
that's gary yes you guys looking great
yeah
thank you pick your partner bigger
pardon okay so you've heard that so once
again i will go
through your names um for against
abstain
um as usual um council coleman cook
this is for the word in that mr
livingston has stated
for council auburn for
council baillyford um i was against
sorry i was for the proposal so
can you advise me you'll be engaged
thank you um councillor curry
for council ghana
four councillor hart against chair
councillor keane four councilloratican
paul uh councillor scott
you're not coming in on this one
explaining again yesterday thank you
uh councillor taylor four
councillor whitehead four
council right against
and me i'm four
so i believe that motion there has been
a carried
uh thank you ian for that
okay um i can't see what the numbers are
but uh
also on my screen here i have um a note
from councillor scots yes
obviously except uh being late i know
you work
matthew and uh regarding the dates of
the meetings i can't answer that at the
moment but i'm sure we can
looking to see what's gone gone wrong
here
thank you
writer and gender item for
b uh which is a planet application for
approval
at three herodine rule says if
an officer will now read out a public
speaking statement
so i'm going back over to suki please
this is the action by ms debbie roberts
statement on behalf of objecting
residents three harrow
dean we hope you have had a chance to
look at the emailed photographs along
with a brief outline of our objections
we contend that the planning officer's
report for this application includes
misleading erroneous and contradictory
information
based on assumptions and have the lack
of supporting evidence
firstly the report references the
adjacent one herodine has having been
completed to a similar plan
1906.08 what it fails to mention
is that following enforcement
proceedings number one is currently
applying for retrospective planning
commission
as it breached its permitted dimensions
as the application for number three is a
significantly larger build
eg 20 taller we question why this
application is even being considered
when it is contrary to other actions
being undertaken by the council
the report references to policy qd02 and
bsp9
are also deceptive the similar
conversion of number one
is visual proof that this proposal is
incompatible with these policies
it does not reflect the design
characteristics of the area
is not compatible with neighboring
buildings and the oversized and overly
dominant dormers would result in an
unbalanced bungalow top-heavy in
appearance
the report states that dormers are
present within haradine and surrounding
streets
however the only dormers we have found
are those few that facilitate bathrooms
are only two meters wide and have been
there since the estate's inception
the assertion in the report that only
glimpses of the extended roof and
dormers can be seen to the west and
south and rugby close
is also reputed in the absence of any
site visits this is totally inaccurate
and we hope the photos will demonstrate
this
when considering policy qd03 living
conditions
numerous objections have been raised to
the applicant's previously submitted
plans and in particular
the overbearing impact the proposal
would have number five harrowing
the 11.5 metre proposed dormers would
run the full length of that garden
creating a vertical wall 2.7 meters high
less than one meter from the boundary
the roof
currently slopes away creating a sense
of space
as the deep dormers proposed are set so
close to the roof edge
that sense of space would instantly
disappear resulting in enclosure
also contrary to qd03 the windows in the
rear gable are clear glazed
and would overlook several properties in
rugby close resulting in loss of privacy
there is only 11 meters between mr
heliwol's property and number three
and 85 of his garden would then be in
full view
similarly mr palmer directly behind the
applicant
would have his immunity space overlooked
in its entirety
neither of these properties currently
experienced this intrusion
in summary the dormers proposed by
reason of their size sighting design and
bulk
represent an overly dominant and
disproportionate addition to the roof of
the property
which detracts from the character and
appearance of the application
site
uh thank you sookie um speaking as ward
counsellor
uh counselor dexter please
can't hear you roy
turn your mic on right yeah i'm trying
to do that right now
you are we can hear you oh can you hear
me now
yes thank you okay well thank you mr
chairman
um i request that members of the
planning committee
consider this application for refusal
the statutory consultant broad stairs
instant peter's town council
on the 5th of october made the unanimous
decision to recommend
that this application be refused
on the grounds that the two dormers will
have an overbearing impact
leading to a sense of enclosure
plus a total loss of the neighbor's
privacy
the public and numerous members of the
saint peter's community
also have many objections and concerns
regarding this proposed extension
including overbearing impact
close to neighbouring properties noise
loss of privacy loss of neighbours
outlook
and loss of light taking into account
the comments of the statutory council t
and the local community i consider this
application to be an
unacceptable development therefore
once again i request that members of the
planning committee
consider this application for refusal
on the grounds of over development
overbearing excessive bulk and scale
overlooking total loss of neighbours
prof sorry privacy detrimental to the
street scene
blocking natural light and contravening
the broad seasons and peter's
neighborhood plan
and section 10 clauses 10 2
and 10 3 of the broad stairs and peter's
town design statement
i.e design and over-dominant
dormers thank you mr chairman and
members
uh thank you councillor dexter i'll ask
the planning officer to
outline the report um is it your
annabelle
yes this is carry on
right hopefully members can see my
screen okay
just a quick update before i do the
presentation
we've had five additional
representations
objecting to the applications since the
agenda
being published they are all from people
who have already commented on the
application
and they do not raise any new concerns
that weren't already summarized in the
committee report
so this is the application site
obviously outlined in red as normal
um number one and number three are set
back
um this part of um the road
with numbers five and seven set further
forward okay to have
rugby close wraps around and to the rear
of the site
so this is the aerial view of the site
this is number one
the application site number three here
and numbers five and seven
and again we can see rugby close uh
wrapping around to the left and
to the rear
and this is an a 3d version of the
applications and the surrounding area
application site and surrounding area
this is number one obviously before
anything has been built on it
the application site number three here
number five and number seven and this is
rugby close uh
running off on the right hand side and
wrapping around
um this so this is a photograph
obviously here is number three the
application site
this is number one um with the dormers
that have
been built i will point out
that has been mentioned this there was
an approval granted for
number one for the reign of the roof
and dormers to the side but it was a
smaller
um dorm as an increase that has
been approved compared to what has been
built out
and i will show you later on in the
presentation
what was actually approved on number one
um but you can see here that number
three sits here and then
numbers five and seven and other
properties as you go further along
haradine are actually two-story
um again you can see the relationship
between
number one uh with the dormers that have
been built out
um which have actually just been um the
application to retain those dormers was
actually refused yesterday
because of the scale and size and
relationship of them
number three sits here and as you can
see it is a
bungalow and again moving further
along haradine you can see number three
the edge of number one with its dormer
and the two story dwellings as you move
further down
um this is looking back the other way
the edge of number five
the application site here and number
with the dormers
as they have been built and so this is
the block plan
you can see number one here
and number three being similar in design
and number five
number seven um sitting forward of that
and
being of a similar design but of
themselves
so this is the existing front elevation
of number three
um this is how it's proposed to be where
you can see the front elevation
the ridge height
sorry the rich high actually increases
by 0.9 meters
um this is actually the plan that was
approved on number one harrowing so this
is the plan that
got on but wasn't built out and i think
you would see there are
similarities with what is being proposed
now at number three
as to what was approved at number one um
not what has been built out and has at
number one has subsequently been
the existing rear elevation
and the proposed rear elevation again
you can see the roof has been raised
and the dormers in situ and the existing
side elevation
and the dormers uh and as
excuse me as has been mentioned the
adoramas would be 11.5 meters long
2.7 meters in height and have a depth of
3.5 meters this is the other existing
side elevation
and again the proposed side elevation
in this instance um the dormers will be
set in from both the front and the rear
by one meter so one meter here and one
meter there
and also set up from the eaves by 0.5
meters and also down from the ridge by
0.5 meters
and they would be tall hung and
all the windows within both dormers
would be obscure glazed
and only have high level um fan lights
that are openable
so we have the the ground floor
and the proposed ground floor um there
are as you would see there are
at a different scale but they broadly
remain the state same there are
some internal um alterations but
it does not physically get bigger it is
just a change in the scale of the
drawings
and then we have the proposed um first
floor
um and has as has been mentioned there
are also windows
as well as the dormers proposed to the
side with the obscure glazed windows
there are is a window proposed to the
rear
and windows facing to the front but
given the
separation distances between the
application site and the surrounding
dwellings
including some 25 meters between the
dwellings
um and the ones to the rear that sorry
number three and the joinings to the
rear
um it is considered that there would be
sufficient space for the developments
take place without um
having an adverse effect on na the
residential amenities of neighbours in
terms of a sense of enclosure
loss of light or overlooking from the
development as proposed
it is a balanced judgment but members
are
obviously sorry are recommending that
the application be approved
thank you thank you annabelle i move the
officer's recommendation
is adopted could the vice chair please
second
or second nature uh thank you councillor
coleman
cook um coming in councillor nama please
yeah thank you thank you chair yeah um
as you've probably seen i called this
this um
application in after speaking to a large
number of the residents around there who
who had concerns and i must say when
when i called it in
uh to be decided by us if the planning
officer was minded to approve it
after looking at the plans and looking
at the next door
extension i was i was wasn't really
expecting it to get this
far i was quite surprised to see it
come up on the agenda um as annabelle
mentioned
uh the plans for this application are
very similar
to those for number one next door which
as she also mentions
were yesterday rejected by
a different planning officer and i think
i've had a look through the report
for the rejection for number one and i
think that that sums up quite well why
why this um should also be rejected i
believe
um so if you don't mind i'll just read
out a couple of sentences from that
which says the dormers lack any sense of
subservience
and our odds with the character and
scale of developments within the area
to approve the proposed works would be
to allow a diminution
in the quality of development previously
approved
contrary to the aims of policy qdo2
of the athenic local plan bsp9 of the
draft board says neighbourhood plan
and the aims of paragraphs 127 and 130
of the mppf i think we've had
um a lot the comments from mrs roberts
at the start summed up a lot of the
reasons why
i think this should be rejected and
counsellor dexter
and we would find ourselves if this were
to be approved
we would find ourselves in a rather
ridiculous situation
of having a builder removing the dormers
from number one
while at the same time building the same
structure
more or less next door at number three
so i can't see any reason why this
application should be approved
thank you thank you council ghana
councillor bateford
thank you chair i also feel that this
uh development is is quite unreasonable
um i think number one looks terrible
um albeit larger than what was
for which permission was given um
i think that the it's a clear example of
an
of over dominant dormers um detracting
from
the street scene and certainly
detracting from the amenity of the
neighbours
so i i can't support this application
thank you chair
uh thank you councilman ford uh before i
bring in council lahart
um annabelle you wish to come back
uh yes please chair i just wanted to
clarify that
um there may have been a bit of a
misunderstanding
um we're not saying the proposal number
three that's before you today is similar
to what's
been constructed at number one it's
rather what has been approved
at number one accepted not the plans
that were refused yesterday
so it's smaller and different to the
plans that were
have been refused yesterday on number
one i.e the plans that have been built
out
um but it is similar to the plans that
were approved
at number one just to give that
clarification to members
uh thank you um councillor hart
yeah thank you chair um i'm in a mind to
agree with a lot of my other councillors
um i think this is another dominant um
building and i think it is a shame
because
some of these estates were built back in
the day
when they wanted a mixture of residents
in the estate so therefore you had four
bedroom detached houses three bedrooms
dummies bungalows so you've got a mix of
people that
lived in that estate so you had a nice
feel about the estate
and i think it's quite a shame that when
you get these bungalows well
an older generation can live and mix
with another generation of people
um that is being lost because people are
being grinding and just want to build up
and
dominate the theory and i think that's
quite a shame and a bad reflection
on our community as such but i also feel
that
this is far too dominant for the scene
there um and i think it's a great shame
that
that houses like this or bungalows like
this are being lost to the community
thank you thank you councillor curry
thank you chair um once again i do feel
this application has a noticeable
adverse effects on the appearance of the
area
and um the uh especially next door
uh the the loss of privacy for number
five if i was living at number five
i would not be happy at all with this
and
i i will not be supporting this
application thank you
uh thank you council curry council ghana
you wish to come back
yeah just just on the on the the
similarities with with number one
i mean i know number one was built
larger
than um than the plans because
the plans didn't work so the plans for
this at number
number three are i believe larger
and higher than their the plans that
were approved
for number one they're not the same as
the plans that were approved for number
one
that's and i agree with obviously all
the other councillors who've
spoken uh thank you for that so
councillorman
yeah thank you chair just a couple of
questions please uh for annabelle
um i just want to go back to nut to
number one
and on the original application that
that
that has been approved and i think we've
got to be circumspect about this
um as far as that is concerned could you
two
took two questions um were there a lot
of objections
in relation to the application that was
approved at number one
and secondly was part of that
that application it was approved at
number one to raise the roof height the
existing roof height
as is as is the case at number three
annabelle um i can answer one of those
questions
yes it was um proposed to raise the
rich height as well as add the dormers
at number one
with the scheme that was approved i
don't have access to the
report for number one but i was aware
there were
some objections i couldn't give you the
exact number
thought that okay can i come back cheer
yes counselor could you advise whether
it was an officer
decision to approve or was it a or was
it a member
decision it was a dedicated decision yes
thank you uh thank you i can't see now
any other speakers so once again i'm
going to put this
uh to you
i put the emotions the opposite
recommendation
for approval uh once again if you four
against or abstain so i'll call your
names out so
counselor common cook against
council robin against councillor bayford
against councillor curry against
council ghana against councillor hart
the gangster councillor keane
against council rashford
again uh casa scott are you with us on
this one
against chet thank you councillor taylor
against councillor whitehead
against council right against
and i am as well um i think that is that
really has
uh that's fallen thank you
uh mr livingston i'll be coming over to
you or
one yeah yeah i i can i can come back on
that chair
thank you um so a number of members have
mentioned the particular point i think
this is the the consistent line is the
concern about the the size and prominent
sighting of those
dorm windows in in their view um
and i think that um there is a there's a
motion that again i could put forward
to um to to members that would i think
encapsulate that and give the policy
background
that to sort of back up those concerns i
did just want to pick up a point
because a couple of members did mention
about the impact on neighboring
properties
um obviously one of the the the things
that
that was was is dealt with in the report
is to ensure that the windows
that face onto neighbours are obscure
glazed and non-opening
above a certain finished floor level so
in officers views i think it would be
difficult
to sustain an objection on overlooking
or loss of privacy
therefore um i suppose the the ground of
of refusal that that a member may wish
to put forward
would be on uh on you know on the
particular concerns of the guards to the
size
and citing the dormers um the particular
policy is is qdo2
the local plan mention was made there of
the
the broadstairs neighborhood plan which
is considered within
the report that is a particular it's a
draft neighborhood plan but
it has weight within the determination
of applications
uh by virtue of the fact that it's
proceeding to referendum
um expected sort of early next year
and that policy particularly talks about
the design
within broad stairs and and and is a
sort of bolstering policy again to
to qdo2 um so
um the the motion that i would suggest
might
wish to be proposed by a member and
please do query this if any
members have got any particular cons you
know questions with regards to the
other issues uh but would be um that the
proposed dorm windows by virtue of this
their size and
prominent sighting uh results would
result in
a visually intrusive incongruous and
dominant form of development
i think that encapsulates what members
were saying
unrelated in scale and design to the
host building
which is something that was brought up
as well uh severely detrimental to the
character of the area
and that would be contrary to qdo2 of
the the thanet local plan
um the policy specifically in the
neighborhood plan which is um
which is uh bs uh
p9 p9 and and then
um and then the paragraphs 127 130 of
the mppf
so that would be the motion that i would
suggest may wish to go forward for them
yes i'd like to propose
emotion along those lines as i i think
as i read out
from the report report for number one
more or less
uh so you you proposed i'd like a second
to please
hold second nature there's a few um
cancer they don't go on this one
okay so once again members i i will go
through your names
uh for against rob stain for the
new motion uh that mr livingston has
read to you um uh councillor coleman
cook
four counts robin
george share four councillor baker
council curry four councillor ghana four
councillor heart georgia
councillor keane four council ratigan
four council scott
fortre council taylor
four council whitehead
four counts the right four
and so am i so uh that's unanimous
thank you very much members on that uh
and again now moving on to
agenda item 4b uh
planning application for refusal land
adjacent to two
sharp place in ramsgate
and officer will now read out the public
speaking
statement in favor of this application
i'll pass over to suki again please
thank you chair
this is from the agent in favor miss
debbie marriage
i clarify a number of points in the
office's report at no point since the
application was validated did the
planning officer tell
us that a unilateral undertaking was
required to mitigate
spa and ramsar impacts had we been
asked we would have drafted one the
officer assert
that the development has a horizontal
emphasis that would be out of keeping
with the area
this is simply incorrect i urge members
to look at the proposed elevations
it is clear that vertical elements are
dominant on all elevations
of the building the window proportions
are similar to the recently approved
dwellings on the opposite side of the
road on chatham street
at 2a park road and echo the sash window
proportions on one
and two shall place far from having
little detailing the facades
have the level of detailing one would
expect on a contemporary building
deep reveals in a contrasting yellow and
a mixed palette of materials give the
building
interest too much detailing would be
overly fussy and detract from the
contemporary aesthetic
the officer asserts that the development
would block light to the rear ground
floor of too
shall place contrary to her report there
is no evidence of a habitable room at
the rear of too
sharp place only a kitchen there are
windows
in the rear of 76 chatham street
but the applicants for daylight study
plans
show that they would receive some
sunlight at different times of day and
year
it must be stressed that this is a
courtyard style development and
some degree of mutual overshadowing will
occur on the inner facades
if this site is to be developed to
require
no overshadowing at all will mean the
site is undevelopable
several times the officer states that
habitable room windows in the proposed
flats would be obscured glazed
she does not explain that the obscure
glazed windows to which she refers
are small secondary windows in the north
elevation and that the lounges to flats
three and four each have two much larger
non-obscured glazed windows in the south
elevation
this is very misleading all the
habitable areas of the proposed flats
have ample windows
and outlook the argument that the roof
terrace is not adequate play space is
unconvincing
surely children are better served to
have an outdoor space
at height away from street level traffic
pollution
if the fencing is considered too
dangerous a planning condition
can be imposed requiring additional
safety features
in any event toddlers are likely to be
supervised on the roof terrace
this application will mean the
redevelopment of a rundown
brownfield site in the center of the
town
no objections have been received from
any neighbours or consul teams
we ask officers to approve this scheme
uh thank you very much suki uh i'm
scanning
asking the planning office to outline
the report who is
you want quiet on me
sorry it's me chairman can you hear me
i've got quite weak signals so i'm
hoping this works can you
no i can hear you yeah thank you nice to
see you thank you
okay so um this is the application site
outlined
in red here so on the left is sharp
place
on the right hand side here is um
margaret road leading into chatham
street
and then to the south here is park road
this is a image of the site so the site
is here the triangular piece of land
surrounded by by these three roads and
the south of the
of the um slide here this is the
conservation area so the site lies
outside of the conservation area but is
is close to the boundary of it
and on this corner here is a listed
building
so this is just a closer shot of that so
you can see that again the little
building here
and the conservation area boundary and
then the the piece of land we're
referring to is this area here which is
um
you can see a undeveloped piece of land
adjacent to existing development so this
is just a few
um views from different angles so again
the application site
here so an existing building's a single
story leading up to two story
um around this section here
and then again this is now taken um
looking from margate road towards the
site
so the application site is this area
here
and then again another view this is now
taken from park road direction again you
can see the site here
so this is number one and two sharp
place existing two-story um
dwellings and then the application site
is this area here
um and you can see that um historically
there
there appears to have been some
attachment to these buildings there's
some historic maps have been submitted
that show there may have been some
historic development within this area
this again is showing the application
site here you can also see quite a
change in ground level
so and there's quite a big change
between um this corner of the site and
the far corner
this is then looking up to number two
sharp place and then this is taken
looking back towards the buildings and
with chatham street and
margaret road on the right hand side and
park road on the left
and again you can see uh the the ends of
the existing building that would be
joining on to
on both sides and from this view as well
you can also see that the rear of number
two
shall place the upper level there's no
um existing windows within the rear of
that
that building and then a closer in
short so it's quite um it's quite a poor
piece of land it's
it's um as i say historically it
probably has some development on it but
it's since been left for a long period
of time and
currently it's um quite detrimental in
terms of
the the view you have of this so it is a
site that
in principle we would be keen to see
developed and have some enhancement of
this area
and this is now looking at the the
building um 76 chatham street so this is
on the right hand side of the
triangular piece of land and now this is
taken from inside the site looking
towards the rear elevation of the
existing building so you can see there's
there are windows um at upper level
within
the property so this is number 76
chatham street
and this is the rear elevation and of
the of the
of the part facing chatham street and
then the the other
frontage on this side and again looking
towards
those windows and this is just showing
examples of other properties in the area
so it's a in quite high density area
and there's a number of terrorist
properties around so you can see this is
an example of a typical
design of properties this is opposite
the site this is um in park
um in park road opposite the site uh
two-story
terrace properties and then this is
boundary road
that leads into the park road you get
examples of terraced properties
you can see in the area this is now
looking
from margaret road back towards the site
so the application site is behind this
building and this is number 76
chatham street and then again one and
two sharp place here
and then this is again just showing one
and two sharp place um
and uh the property opposites there's
not really any frontage opposite the
size
side elevation here and on this area
here
and then this is now looking from the
conservation area towards the site so
the listed building is this property
here
on the right and again the application
site is this area here
so um in considering this that so the
proposal is for a two to three-story
building
containing two two bed flats and two one
bed flats
so this is the elevation onto sharp
place so this again is number one and
two sharp place
and this is the proposed building
joining onto it so it's two story in
height
with a flat roof and with a parapet wall
at the front
and you can see that there's no entrance
door onto this
area so looking in terms of the pattern
of development
you can see that everything around here
is quite has quite a vertical emphasis
so again the properties here both um
single units
with entrance doors but the proposal
here is is um showing a number of
different windows
this is now wrapping around so this is
now fronting onto park road so this is
the full
width of the development and again you
can see through from this plan
the real change in ground level so it
starts at two stories
where it was in sharp place but by this
point here it's reached three stories
and therefore the story and then drops
again in order to achieve
two stories again um extending onto this
corner
um there's a single entrance point into
the building which is in this location
here
and you can see again the windows
designs has a variety of window
proportions
along here different window designs and
some smaller
some longer windows
and this now wraps around to the other
side this again now is 76
chatham street so this property here is
two-story drop into single story
but again because of the ground level
difference this now at two-story level
is not significantly higher than the
single-story element of
76 chatham street and again you can see
on this
element here again there's no entrance
onto onto the street
at a roof level there's a roof terrace
being provided
and because of the constrained um size
and shape of the site there's limited
space so there's no
um yard area or garden area being
provided for the units other than
at roof level so this is the the door
set play space area that's being
provided for the development
and this this is just showing the
internal um view of the building so
this is um the rear elevation internally
of of the buildings as it wraps around
so this is just um some visuals showing
the development so this is the
elevation that would be fronting park
road
again showing the the ground level
changes
and the height changes and again you can
see now the the roof terrace area
and then this taken again from the other
side so with
park road um on the left and chatham
street on the right
and again you can see the the changing
in window shapes and again the roof
terrace
and its relationship with the building
behind at this level you can also see
that
in order to try and prevent any
overlooking of the property behind
a mesh roof screen area has been
provided along the rear of the roof so
in order to prevent overlooking down
into the windows
this is the ground floor plan of the
development
um so it's showing a two bed flat on the
right hand side here
the central access point um into the
building
and then on the left is refuse stores
and cycle storage areas
this is a first floor level so you can
see there there's a
a single bedroom flat on the left and a
two bedroom flat on the right hand side
here
accessed from this central staircase and
there are
windows provided within the rear
elevation it's proposed that these would
be
obscure glazed um but there is some
concern the fact that there will be
obscure glaze into these windows and
therefore the impacts for the future
occupiers of the development and the
fact that that will
um reduce uh light and outlook
within the room served by those windows
this is the second floor plan so showing
again the one bedroom flat on the left
and then the roof terrace area on the
right hand side here
um and then this again is just a roof
plan now showing just that roof terrace
area and the flat roof area here
so in terms of the proximity to the
properties behind you can see in terms
of one and two sharp place in this area
here and then 76 chatham street it's
in quite close proximity to the building
so for example this
line here is showing a distance of only
eight meters between the rear
section of this building and um the the
roof level so it's very close proximity
so
concern has been raised with the impact
to windows within
this rear area and daylight studies have
been submitted which have shown
that given the location of the
development the south of the site
and the movement of any of the sun
around it would
significantly block light and outlook
from these windows
this is just a section plan showing
again the relationship between
the proposed development and the
existing building so the proposed
amendment
on um the right here and the existing
builders on the left
and then a section plan again from park
road just showing the
height of the building and again the
roof terrace area and then this is
a plan showing the impact on windows
so again from roof terrace level there
would have been some overlooking but the
screening has been
proposed and this is the internal
elevation looking back out again
showing that these would be obscure
gray's windows and again a roof terrace
level
this is the example here of the the mesh
privacy screening that's proposed at the
rear at
a height of 1.8 meters um
so again just to just to look at the
impacts on the neighbors
this property here as you as you saw has
no upper level
windows but there are windows located
within the rear of the properties here
so it is felt that there will be a
significant impact on
the light and outlook of these windows
furthermore as you can see there's
there's limited space um
for um dorset play space and therefore
this is located at roof level
um and this is considered to be sort of
unacceptable location
in order to achieve secure doorstep play
space
um so it's considered that this isn't
particularly safe with a 1.4 meter high
railings around it it's not particularly
um secure and safe doorstep place space
for children and therefore
that that has been another concern in
terms of the actual design of the
development
um whilst it is appreciated that this is
a difficult site to try
and um to try and develop and whilst we
would encourage the
the development of the site because of
the existing um ice or off
of the site the concern of the
development
is that it appears quite wide and quite
a big mass
so whereas the surrounding area has a
lot of vertical emphasis with terrorist
properties
each with their own entrance door onto
the road um with with windows above
this in comparison is an extremely wide
um looking development but again i'm
your single
entrance door at this point here is
so it's considered it has quite a
horizontal emphasis and
this is further exacerbated by the flat
roof design that's proposed so again on
the existing building it's got the pitch
roof
around it whereas this is now entirely
flat roof
along the full width of the building
it's also there's also concern there's
limited detailing in the building so
there's no
headers above windows and the window
hierarchy
isn't what you would expect within um
historic buildings where you would
usually have larger windows at ground
floor and then these may reduce in size
as you go
go higher higher up these again you can
see a variety of different window sizes
which aren't really
um traditional for historic area and an
area with that's faulted in the setting
of the conservation area
so um the only the other concern is is
the rooftop is the actual visual impact
of the roof terrace so it
seems to be quite an alien feature at
roof level
um it's shown on the planet there would
be seating areas and tables and things
so you would be expecting
that people would be um using this space
um and the concern is that from the
views from the conservation area looking
towards this space it's very prominent
and has long views of this roof terrace
and it's not again a typical feature
that you would expect
on a building within um the setting of a
conservation area
so this is quite an alien feature that
we wouldn't wouldn't expect to see so
this actually also
um causes harm to the character of the
area
um in terms of the impact on the listed
building given the distance and the
orientation it's not just that there
will be
any impact on the setting of that
building
in terms of um highways this the site
doesn't provide any off street parking
but it does provide cycles parking
spaces
um and the site is within easy walking
distance of ramsgate town center so it's
considered to be quite sustainably
located
and therefore the lack of any parking is
not considered to to cause harm um
to to the highway to highway safety
so overall there the concerns do the
design
um in terms of the the actual detailing
and also the
horizontal emphasis and mass of the
building is considered to cause harm to
the character appearance of the area and
the setting of the conservation area
the location of the building is also
considered significant impact to
light and outlook from the existing
property and the lack of doorstep play
space is also a concern
in addition there has not been um a
unilateral undertaking submitted to
secure the special protection
contribution um and therefore these are
all reasons for refusal and therefore
it's recommended for refusal thank you
uh thank you emma uh i know the
officer's recommendation is adopted
could the vice chair please
second old second nurture
thank you council common cook um i will
go straight over to
councillor orban please yeah thank you
chair
um this site has been derelict for ages
um and uh something needs to be done
with it
but not this uh this is totally
an utterly wrong design it might be a
right for ikea
uh but not for a not for flat station
it should be in that area in my humble
opinion should be a more
traditional design um
i just think they're cramming they're
just cramming that space for
um and as for and as for the roof
terrace we'll
vehicle pollution will go up
you know it will go up so any kids on
the top of that
on top of that uh roof roof terrace will
probably choke to death
um i totally support
totally natalie support the the officers
recommendations and uh i hope the rest
of the
committee do too thank you chair uh
thank you councillor
and um councilman thank you chair
i also support the officer's
recommendation um
i understand that there is need for
development in this into space but i
i agree entirely with councillor alban
this is not not the one
um i think it's visually unattractive
externally and internally um
i with the obscured wind the windows
i think um
what can i say i think it would be um
quite um uncomfortable for
for for people living there that uh and
i also
feel that the roof terrace terrace is
dangerous
in terms of um uh
the height and danger of falling and
also
of um pollution so
i i totally agree that i i with the
officer's recommendation
would like to refuse this this
application thank you chair
yesterday uh councillor taylor yeah
fully
back what um annabelle has said tonight
um and
council organs said and actually wrote
down about the vehicle
um vehicles will pass it's such a busy
junction there
and the vehicle fumes well that's going
to
add to it and it's such a bulky looking
building i just can't see
how you make good of that space it's
just too it's too much
i agree it does need developing and it
certainly needs a tidy up if
i can go ahead even without this develop
development
if it is um approved but i'm definitely
supporting the officer's recommendation
of
refusal thank you councillor taylor
council ghana
thank you yeah i'm i'm in agreement with
what's been said
um but this is and also in agreement
this does
need developing it does need something
on it uh some
um somewhere some homes on it um how i
was just wondering how
much conversation has there been with
the applicant
to get to the stage where they've put in
an application which
is totally unsuitable have they been
are we able to engage much more to
enable them to put in a more acceptable
proposal
um and i agree with what council tayden
said about him needing to tidy up
i mean we could see that car that must
have been there
a number of years because he spray
painted could we at least get it
the applicant to tidy up the the site
thank you emma did you want to come back
on that at all
um yes so um i mean we did carry out
pre-application advice on this one and
we did advise that is a site we would
be keen to see developed but you know
advise them of the of the difficulties
with developing this site and the fact
that they need to take into account
the impact on on the neighboring windows
and try and get a good design so
this isn't quite it from our point of
view but you know there will be
something that will fit on this site and
i think it'd be a matter of
if members support our officer
recommendation at this stage then the
applicant will have
um sort of something to work with in
terms of how they can deal with that and
hopefully come back in with a revised
application
that addresses the concerns that we've
raised
thank you emma um councillor curry
thank you chair i must say this is an
incredibly imaginative work by the
architect to
cram so much into a relatively small
place
but it it does scream of over
development
and i will be supporting the officer's
recommendations thank you
thank you carrier counselor scott
thank you chair um yeah it's it's an
agreement with all the other councillors
and the officers really
um it's just a shame i mean i've always
wanted to encourage
brownfield in um building and developing
on brownfield sites
um it's always welcome but it just seems
to be that
developers can't ever seem to get it
right it's always over developed or
designed it's not in the character and
it's just it's frustrating because there
is an area that
will and does need development but not
of this kind and um
yeah again i will be for the officers on
this one so thank you chair
thank you council right thank you
chairman um
i i agree with with everything everybody
else has
said but i would add i think this this
development is more about profit than it
is
housing and a contribution to the
environment
thank you uh thank you
um yes i go along with it the site is a
dreadful site and as you say it's been
like it for many many years but uh
i go along with members on this one okay
i can't see anybody else
wishes to speak so i'm going to put this
to you which is the officer's
recommendation is for
refusal uh once again please
members if you're for the refusal or
against
or you're abstaining please let me know
um
counselor common cook for
councillor organ for council bayford
yeah have we lost you jill sorry chair
four thank you uh councillor curry
for council ghana four
councillor heart forget councillor keane
four councillor raskin four
councillor scott four councillor taylor
four councillor whitehead
four council right four
and myself i'm four as well
and i think that is unanimous
uh that we go along with the officer's
recommendation for
the refusal thank you members um
that concludes the public speaking for
this meeting i will call upon the clerk
to read out the remaining
planning application um if a member
wishes to reserve and uh this
application please will they
call out as he reads um
we'll ask james i think it's james the
readout
gender item for c which is land rear of
nine o'clock court ramsgate
thank you very much chair um as you've
said there for me it is
agenda item 4c land rear of nine open
court in ramsgate
thank you thank you does anybody wish to
speak on this
don't okay um can i have a proposal to
move that the
application here that have not been
reserved be determined in accordance
with the officer's recommendation
uh could i have a second to please i'll
second that yeah
thank you councillor alban uh the
members agree
agreed to agree great thank you
thank members uh agenda item
five which um some members will recall
has been with us before
i hope you've read the very long report
interesting reading
and um
i will lastly i think it is in
livingston
yes yeah thank you ian um to read out
the outline report
thank you
thank you chairman i'll just share my
screen
and uh okay can can everyone see
yes see that excellent okay um
so members will recall uh this
uh application previously been put
forward in
august this year to recap
about this site um so this is uh
an application site where we have an
application for 250 houses it was
resolved for approval in august 2017 uh
subsequent to that there had been
viability discussions going on uh best
part of a couple of years
and then in august the application was
presented back to members
with a recommendation of reducing the
amount of affordable housing from
30 percent uh to 18
with a split about 18 being 70 percent
affordable rent
and 30 shared ownership as it was then
on the basis of the evidence and the
analysis of the viability of the scheme
members deferred back to officers for
further negotiation
and potential reasons for refusal um and
so the report has been
put to members um along those lines so
just to give you a quick uh run through
the slides just so everyone's uh
familiar with the scheme again so this
is the application
site in red so you have
coffin house corner just out of shots
you have um since you're
uh some gregory school here you have
natch road
running down uh the side of the uh
the site here and you have uh the
um cemetery in the crematorium
uh in the bottom here so giving you the
aerial view and it's
taken from google so it's got some of
the the points of interest on there so
you can see the intersection of shot and
dane road and manson road here
as well as the coffin house corner
junction
here so this
is a an isometric view just again
showing the
the the landscape and showing quite
clearly delineating the site
between all of these bits of development
so this application site is allocated in
the
local plan as adopted in in july for 250
homes
it also includes in yellow through the
site here
or one of the key parts of
infrastructure within the district as
part of the
transport strategy so this is one of the
link roads
uh that effectively will create almost a
loop around
the bottom half of coffinhouse corner as
well as
with the uh the site uh
opposite and down a little bit which is
currently subject to an application
that's with
the planning department so as mentioned
that's
that's the the site is allocated for
housing so the principle of development
is acceptable
um this is an illustrative plan showing
how
the development could be accommodated on
the site
uh the particular points i'd like to
make members aware of
um that they uh to keep in mind are the
road infrastructure improvements and
proposals for any roundabout
uh at the western part of the site
on manston road then also then there's
the obviously the link through the site
and then there's a change in roads a
layout at
this point here so nash roadwood would
basically come
into this site and then there'll be a
junction coming
off to go down nash road um
and if i skip through these plans this
is a
a technical drawing of what the
roundabout would
look like at madison road
and then this is the arrangement i
mentioned about nash road in terms of
the realignment
uh and the particular point of interest
here in terms of coffinhouse corner is
that
the application would include some
off-site highways works as well
one of those is to close off uh the nash
road
arm of coffin house corner to reduce
that down from being a five
junction junction to only four arms on
that junction
resulting in improvements in terms of
the signaling times and
to try and relieve some of the
congestion that occurs there you still
have
access up to empire terrace via nash
road
as well as that there is a proposal at
the uh part of the site that well
close to the site at where uh manson
road meets shotendone road
um and this is a a key change in the
prioritization of this road
so um members will probably be familiar
with this junction that
you uh you queue at manchester road to
come on to shondane road
um but actually that would be changed so
that actually the
priority would be on manson road and you
would join it
from schondane road and that's because
traffic is then
aiming to move up to the new roundabout
and then link
through the other development site that
i
showed you on this slide here
so um to pick up the particular points
in the report
um so um a further option
has been proposed by the applicant annex
9 of the report
includes a letter from the applicant in
response following the committee
meeting the option that's been put
forward by the applicant
is that 30 of the dwellings on the site
would be
affordable housing as defined by the
mppf
however due to the viability evidence
that's been prepared and
that officers have analyzed that 30
would not include a requirement for
affordable rent
so it may be different types of
affordable housing depending on
what the market dictates and what um you
know what could come out so
that at annex 10 of the report it
includes a bit
a definition of what covers affordable
housing in the
uh in the mppf so that could include
shared ownership
it could include discount market rent um
it could include starter homes if that
sort of comes back and comes to fruition
so it covers mainly affordable housing
ownership products
but it wouldn't include automatically
affordable rent
any affordable rent that would be
provided would not be obligated by
a legal agreement to do so but that
option would secure the 30 percent
in terms of the overall policy number
um so it would not though
uh obviously providing that 30 it would
not
accord with the provisions within policy
sp 23
uh of the local plan because it wouldn't
meet the proportions
as set out in our strategic housing
market assessment and subsequent
documents
which is what identifies the type of
affordable housing we
most need in thana and as um put forward
in the previous report and i'm sure as
you're aware that that is uh affordable
rent um which is obviously one of the
drivers behind
officers putting forward and agreeing
the option of
18 on the basis that seventy percent of
that so thirty one of the dwellings
would be affordable rent
with a hundred percent nomination rights
coming to the council
um in terms of policy sp 23
um paragraph uh
3.1 of the report in front of members um
covers a part of uh the affordable
housing policy in the local plan
and i just want to read specifically
what that says
and that is that um the above
requirements
and that's in relation to 30 affordable
housing and setting and meeting those
proportions
will only be reduced if meeting them
would demonstrably make the proposed
development
unviable now from the officers analysis
and from using the consul the
independent consultant's view of the
viability which has been
provided to members meeting the
requirements
would make this scheme unviable
now i understand the concerns of members
obviously i was at the meeting
previously
and one of those concerns was about the
president being set
um i think it's important to say that
this this application and the
consideration of viability of schemes
does not set a precedent when looked at
between
different sites then you know the policy
and the national guidance specifically
makes provision
for this type of situation when there is
a viability
question in this instance the
site specific costs of the off-site
highways works which are needed
for to mitigate the impact of the
development and also
the provision of the the local
distributor standard road through the
site and the roundabout
um you know impacts on the viability of
the scheme
now these changes these these elements
of the scheme
are required for the benefit of the road
network and also to contribute towards
the fanuc transport strategy which is
obviously part of
uh you know the local plan it's it's
integrally linked to the fact local plan
and how the development
of the district will occur to 2031.
but we will always consider evidence
that's put forward on viability
on those sites where infrastructure
needs to be provided to support the
development and there's
site-specific reasons why um a case
might be made
but it does not mean in every single
case
that we take that face value
we will we rigorously look at these
these documents
we obviously get an independent
consultant to look at them as well who
is charged by us to analyze the
viability of it um but in this instance
we do consider that the evidence is
there and is sound
um section three of the report talks
about
the uh potential reasons for fusion and
looks at particularly two points
that come out of the viability evidence
to look at
the you know the potential argument for
um
for not agreeing the inputs into that
viability assessment and it particularly
looks at two points one is the benchmark
land value
so it's the value of the land that the
residual land value is compared against
when you
work out everything every property being
sold and taking away all the development
costs and you compare that residual land
value
to a benchmark land value that benchmark
land value is often dictated by a
combination of factors such as
the market such as the existing use
value it can include
a premium on a land value to
um to accommodate the fact that sites
such as this are allocated um
in that in this instance the analysis
carried out by
the council's independent consultant has
ratified the benchmark land value as 130
000 per
acre as an input into viability
the other issue that's raised in this
section is about the profit
uh and this is at the highest
point of the range of the mbpg so that's
the months
planning practice guidance sets for the
range of
profit on gdv now in this instance
taking account of all factors those two
inputs have been considered appropriate
as mentioned given that the profit is
within the accepted range of the
national guidance
and the benchmark land value has been
independently verified as sound
when looking at the market that that
that that is considered to be an
acceptable input in this case
um because obviously in terms of a
refusal
on the grounds that the site is viable
that obviously has to be backed up with
a
a specific um a specific argument
in relation to the evidence that has
been presented to members
uh and it is worth stating i think again
that um
you know the specific departure from
policy sp23
is only allowed as a result of the
evidence and the test of the evidence
that occurs
um so what's obviously been put to
members
is the recommendation as as previously
put last month
um with uh you know with the additional
information provided in the report so
we consider that the reduction is
acceptable on the basis of the evidence
um whilst also accounting for the
specific economic
and social benefits of the delivery of
an allocated housing site
um providing the key infrastructure uh
providing the contributions that come
out of development
such as this as well as the housing
which again is part of our housing need
to 2031. um but the specific
recommendation is is actually to
recommend the reduction to 18
with the 70 30 split to provide those
affordable rent
properties with again 100 nomination
rights being held by the council
um to put people that are on the
register uh
into those properties um so the the
option
is at 5.1 of the report
um the other point that this has in that
recommendation
or in that option is the addition of
two new conditions to the
um to this uh outline application
uh as a result of the adoption of the
local plan
um and it also we still require the
legal agreement
uh to actually uh you know the details
within it and secure the details of the
obligations
so therefore the recommendation is is to
defer to officers for approval
on the basis of the recommendation of
5.1
the other option um is is the option of
5.2
which would be that if members are not
minded to
accept the reduction the overall amount
of affordable housing which is
recommended by officers
uh 5.2 is um is putting forward that
um that this would that the provision
would stay at 30 percent
um but it would it would exclude
affordable housing for rent so you'd
keep the same amount of affordable
housing and it would accord with the
definition of the mppf
so that's a key point but it wouldn't
wouldn't provide the affordable rent
properties and that's on the basis of
the viability evidence
that's been provided and so
just to just to make it quite clear
though the recommendation is is for the
motion
uh that would be put forward in 5.1 uh
of the report
thank you jim uh thank you ian
i i move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted because the
vice chair please
second off circle nurture
thank you council coleman cook several
speakers here
um council heart
thank you chair um i remember this very
well and i was very vocal on this at the
time i believe
um i understand and i
prefer to go for the
um one where we have a reduced
allocation of houses but it goes to
affordable rent
because i think that is what is the
right thing to do
however um i do i would like just to
have some confirmation ready from ian
um if this gets to three years down the
line
they've just started to put a spade in
the ground the value of properties goes
up immensely
and there is even more profit to be had
can that then go into affordable
rental properties and secondly
what is the thing that in five years
time when he's
or seven years time and he's bought all
these houses he turns around
well i can't give you um 70
rent on the 18 is what happens then
where do we go from there is it just
another way of trying to worm out giving
um affordable rentable properties to
the populace thank you
ian can you answer that please thanks
thank you
so um to take the the first point what
um what the legal agreement that would
be entered into would do
would it would secure the amount the
overall proportion of affordable housing
and it would also secure certain
elements
that would need to be submitted as part
of the legal agreement to the council
for consideration which would be
primarily considered actually by the
council's housing team and that would
include
an affordable housing scheme to be
submitted now obviously what we
have this is an outline application with
you know all that southern
access reserve so we don't know which
properties would be the affordable
properties and which ones wouldn't
so that would be a matter for either
dealing
through the reserve matters application
which would come in
or through a submission to the legal
agreement now
in terms of um if market conditions
improved in the future
whether or not it was suitable for ace
a um what has been considered in the
past a sort of clawback mechanism
clawback mechanisms usually will only
work over a
longer time period which would work
potentially on larger sites
so you will recall the site at madison
green
where members agreed to reduce the
amount of affordable on a particular
phase on the basis that a clawback
mechanism
was inserted and that's because that
scheme was for 800 houses and it was
clearly delineated in different phases
and therefore it would come forward over
a longer time
period um whereas this this development
will be coming forward relatively
quickly in comparison and therefore
it's unlikely that any clawback
mechanism would see
a sufficient uplift in order to carve
out enough
money to increase the amount of
affordable housing
to come back on the second point um
this is something that is as mentioned
actually at the start he's secured
through the legal agreement
so in terms of um implementing the
planning commission if granted
um they would not be able to um sort of
continue the development if they weren't
according to the legal room and if they
carried on without according to the
legal agreement and providing the
affordable rent
properties um that that would be secured
to the lead women
then effectively it is a a breach of
that agreement
and we are and we are looking at
proceedings effectively
um so you know it is considered that
it's unlikely with that legal agreement
which goes with the land as well
so the important point that if it's sold
off to someone else they can't just pick
up and just ignore the legal agreement
um it is something that goes with
successes and title so
we would be confident that the
affordable housing will be secured
as go through through a legal agreement
going into the future
uh thank you for that ian um cancel the
whitehead
with the greatest respect to all
involved
what we're faced with is to my mind
to unacceptable options
we it's been well established
that the type of affordable housing
is incredibly significant for thano
we need affordable ring that's our
demographic
all developers involved in this know
that
a an offer effectively of 30
but entirely excluding affordable rent
can't ever have been thought as an
acceptable offer
there isn't any way that i think any of
us would support that because
what we need as an area is affordable
rent
desperately need homes for people
so to say that it's 30 without
affordable rent
versus accepting a dramatic cut
i can't see how either of these is
acceptable
i fully accept the limitations of the
system we work within
um i fully accept that we are between
two stalls at this point
but that that's what's come back is
disappointing in terms of the
ineffect counter offer that's been made
here because no one can have thought
that
anyone here would think that that's a
good idea
so it's effectively saying we have to
accept a reduction
in order to provide homes for people
um and that's something that upsets
me greatly i
i urge people to think about what we
need
as an area which is affordable rent
above any other type
i accept that what we're faced with is a
reduction
i disagree wholeheartedly with that
even whilst understanding the commercial
pressures involved
but i am asking if there is an
intermediate ground here
if we are to accept a reduction and we
know that what we need in this area is
affordable rent
to my mind we need to be saying actually
if we're accepting a reduced percentage
then we need to be determining that
reduced percentage and we need to be
saying actually we need
90 affordable rent we need more
affordable
and if you're cutting this then you are
cutting
the area that frankly doesn't
provide for us and i fully understand
that there are business issues here i
fully understand that
we are somewhat tied but this is hugely
important for us
and i think it would be wrong for me to
not speak out on it at this point
thank you thank you councillor why hey
and did you want to come back from
council whitehead's comments
um yes i i think i mean i
just want one one point that i i didn't
mention in my presentation
was um about the council's adopted
housing strategy
um now it you know it outlines
that obviously there are kind of a
couple of
couple of points here one is one is
about the point that counselor
had stated about affordable rent being
you know the most most in need and it is
it is the priority of the council within
the housing strategy to provide
those um you know to provide homes for
those on low incomes
um i mean the other point in the the
housing strategy
you know is we do
obviously want to be uh
proactive with developers to try and
deliver
housing sites and that does result in
uh sometimes looking at the the you know
the
you know reduction in in things like
affordable housing
um it would only be done and it is only
done and put forward to members
um when there is the evidence behind it
um
the particular query about you know
wanting
a greater proportion of affordable
housing sorry for affordable rent
off the 18 percent obviously what has
been put forward is
on the basis that any more than that any
any more affordable rent
which obviously has a reduced value in
comparison to
shared ownership um would make the
scheme unviable
and again that's the you know the
evidence that has been presented to
members
that has been looked at um so whilst i
you know i you know i agree i i agree
with the principles behind it this is
obviously why we've
we've offered the recommendation we've
offered on on the first option
um but you know it is it is a case that
the option of the amount of affordable
rent to be provided those
31 of the 45 affordable
is is the amount that we agree is is the
maximum that can be provided before the
scheme becomes unviable
thank you chair uh thank you ian
councillor bayford thank you chair
um whilst i totally agree that the
um percentage loss of affordable housing
is regrettable
and it desperately needs um
accommodation that is for rent
that is affordable and for the reasons
given and the evidence produced i think
have to support the officer's
recommendation
that the um option 5.1 is adopted
thank you chair uh thank you councilman
ford uh councillor keane
i did put my questions been answered now
thank you
thank you councillor keane i just saw
that you come up on the screen there
thank you
councillor ghana yeah thank you um
i've i mean i fully understand and
support
what was said by councillor whitehead
earlier
um about the um the
great need for affordable not just
affordable housing but
affordable rent housing and i find it
i do i find it very difficult to support
either of these
of these proposals um and one of one of
the
reasons i do struggle with this
is to understand what what
i've read the letter from the developer
and to understand the abnormality of the
extra costs
that they're they're now stating around
the
the roads that need to be and the
roundabout that need to be developed
that that has i don't understand why
that has come as a surprise
because when i looked at the um at the
original report on this that went to the
was approved in 2017
i saw a couple of conditions there
around
the need for these new roads so they
knew they knew what was
that what was needed when they approved
this
and looking at the history of how the
estimates of how that
how much that was going to cost which of
which was
i understand it originally 1 million
they then did
during their valuation decided it was
actually 5.1 million as part of their
evaluation report
but seem to quite readily accept
kcc coming back with their own
assessment of 3.8 million
it seems like that has been a bit of a a
negotiation
tactic by them almost to get the
num the percentage of affordable housing
reduce and i do i really do struggle
with that um and so i'm
i'm i mean i'm i'll listen to what
others have got to say obviously
but i i'm going to find it really
difficult to support either these
these proposals thank you
uh thank you council ghana um looking
down here
um you're not gonna hear anybody else
because i haven't got any other names um
so i'm gonna put this uh recommendation
of
officer's recommendation to defer and
delegate which is
fine get right
yes it's just flashed up thank you
carry on steve
wherever you've gone
i think we've lost councillor alban from
the moment
sorry jack we just confirmed that when
we vote the five-point minings for which
one it is
can we just confirm that when we do it
because
the 5.1 is the reduction but
the rate isn't it
yeah that's correct thank you i'm sorry
chair i lost my signal
just for a second no don't worry america
council went off yep
um yeah i i have to say i'm i'm
i feel the same way as councillor
whitehead and
i don't just feel like we're between a
rock and a hard place
and uh and i'm finding it difficult
however
uh there is the other option that
if we don't come up with something this
evening then
this development won't get built at all
and
if it's not built at all then there are
no houses for rent or any affordable
houses so
um whilst we could ask
whilst we could ask our officers to go
back and renegotiate i think as
asean has said as he's had uh we've had
an independent person come in and look
at this as to what's affordable and what
isn't
um then um i have to say
reluctantly uh that i i will go with the
officer's recommendation chair
uh thank you for that councillor alban
uh i
can't see anybody else
yes sir cancer whiteheads just come on
that's the whitehead
council right head
can't hear you
i'm forever doing that um i think as
everyone knows i'm fairly pragmatic um
if things need to be done then you need
to get on and do them
my point mainly in speaking before was
to emphasize the fact that because of
the way the systems work we are having
we're being forced to make choices
that aren't suitable for our community
they're what's best for our community
because people need houses
but their choices that we're being
railroaded into by the way that we are
forced to develop
and i don't that's acceptable but
in terms of what we need to provide
there is a pragmatic way to do it
and that's to support the affordable
rent option
but i do think that people need to be
aware that
we are effectively
tied a lot of the time by the systems
that
we have to be part of and that affects
our ability to serve our community
and that's something that we can all
look at and all think about how to
change at this kind of level
thank you thank you council so i totally
understand
and i'm sure other members know exactly
what i'm
talking about um okay members
um yes uh council
you want to put back yeah just to say
absolutely what helen has said i mean
it's with great reluctance that i will
feel i have to agree with this
so thank you
thank you uh counselor keen i think um
in the future we're going to see similar
and not preempting
anything but um very difficult decisions
and obviously a lot of work has gone on
in the background on this by officers
and
others so um i'm going to put this
to the vote i think you know how it
works now so i'm just going to go
through the names
um council coleman cook
four is that point one
five one five point one
uh councillor auburn for
council bayford four
for council ghana
i'm struggling to say it before
that's the heart with councillor gardner
i think
it's a shame but i will i will agree i
am for this but i think it's a shame
i think we've been forced into a
situation
thank you council heart council for
council raskin for council spots
yeah just to make a comment as well
chair i mean agreeing with
other countless i mean i feel like i
can't make a decision
on this it's not a fair decision so i'm
going to have to abstain
thank you um councillor taylor
abstaining to chair
councillor whitehead with great regret
for a councillor right
reluctantly for
yes i i feel the same um as i've said
it is a difficult one but we've been
given the right advice
and um i i will go for four as well
um i believe that motion has been
carried my
i can't let you come back uh you know
counselor heart
they've taken the vote
all right about the vote chair sorry i
just wanted to make a general comment
sorry
go on on this occasion because i see
that ian wishes to have a
quick word with us um yep
thank you i mean i think all of us are
very
sad to agree to this reduction
um in the way it's been done and i think
we all feel that this should not happen
again
and i would hope that this will not
happen again and if it does i think it
will get refused
and i hope it does get refused because
this is the wrong decision
but we've been forced into it and it's
the second time we've made this decision
and i think we should all turn around
and fight be honest with ourselves and
say
it's not going to happen again story
chair i've never
you for that council heart to say i know
we can't preempt
other planning applications that will be
coming
um in front of us in the future which um
obviously there's gonna be some
quite big ones and uh but i do
understand
members comments here tonight uh ian you
wanted to say
um a few words yeah i i just just
should we throw the meeting to a close
first is that okay
yeah sorry just come in i just wanted to
confirm that motion was
carried and then and then yeah i'd just
like to speak to members afterwards
about
separate uh separate elements if that's
okay i know
um so yes thank you members so that
concludes
uh planning today on the 11th through
11th um
thank you very much um and i think you
have seen that we meet again
next week a little bit of a smaller
agenda um
5 15 and uh i will
have a chat with me and at some stage
because i understand
one of our members didn't get the
information and so forth which can
happen
i'm not blaming him so thank you